[Music]
on today's show we talked to a man whose
father just passed away and he's worried
about his little brother we also talked
to a brand new wife and she's struggling
with her sister who's got special needs
we talked to a woman who's about to
leave an abusive marriage and she's
struggling with guilt stay tuned
[Music]
what up what's up this is john with the
dr john deloney show so glad you're here
so glad you're here we're talking about
mental health relationships
dealing with the the
mayhem all of us i'm so glad you're here
if you want to be on our show give me a
shout one eight four four six nine three
thirty two ninety one that's one eight
four four six nine three three two nine
one or go to johndaloni.com
ask
a couple of housekeeping things don't
forget
please go to johndelene.com and pick up
the new book if you pre-order now tons
of
stuff that comes with your pre-order for
like 20 bucks you get
tons of you get free counseling you get
uh audio books all kind of stuff the the
reader cop reviews are coming back and
man this is humbling to say the least um
never could have imagined the book is
resonating like it is and so go check it
out and
if this show if you like it um let
somebody know be cool if everybody who
listens to it just afforded one episode
that they like
um to somebody that they care about or
that they think might like the show too
so let's get passing it around and do
all the subscribes and all that kind of
stuff
um
i want to read one read one thing and
then have a moment james i'll start with
a moment so james i gotta give you a
this is gonna be a first for our show
it's a positive shout out
so
uh when i was recording the audiobook
it i had
james
would talk into my ear because james was
recording the engineering audio book too
and uh producing the audiobook i don't
know what's the least offensive way i
can say that is there a bet just keep
going all right so
but you said man you
talk to yourself so
poorly like so negatively because i
would do these takes and i'd be like you
idiot or gosh
freaking [ __ ] do this
and then another one of the engineers
are there pulls me aside and they're
like hey
the way you talk to yourself like you
gotta stop that and then a third person
was like hey i don't know if anyone said
anything to you
and so i was like man kind of feeling
like we're having like getting hassled
here a little bit
and then i talked to my wife i was like
man these guys said i
just trashed myself all the time and she
got kind of choked up man she said
it breaks my heart that somebody who i
love so much
talks so poorly about themself
so then i was like man now everybody's
ganging up on me as because i'm always
going to try to make myself a victim
digging up for you
thank you
so anyway i just started watching it
myself
oh my gosh
i would fight me if i wasn't me
i think i do fight me i think that's the
problem i'm working this out live on the
air right now
i've so anyway now i'm gonna talk bad
about myself about how bad i talk about
myself so
this weekend i just had a moment and i
heard my son say something he said
something to himself like gosh what a
dummy or something like that and he was
laughing when he said it
but i immediately was like i gotta stop
because he's watching and learning from
me
and
so man that's my new that's my new thing
i'm gonna spend the rest of 2022 really
shifting the way i talk to myself
and just negative self-talk and this
isn't some kind of woo like i just want
to project in whatever i want to
manifest no none of that nonsense
but i started treating myself a little
more kindness so here's what that looks
like for me this morning
i have an obnoxious morning routine i go
through all the paces and do all the
stuff to get this stuff all done
and i have somehow shifted that you're
supposed to do that and i am like that's
the way i stay well
but when i get through it all and it's a
pretty extensive routine
i think
yep
on to the next
and that's fine but this morning i
shifted a little bit and i said
outstanding way to go
and just that shift of ooh you finally
did everything you're supposed to to
that was hard this morning you did a
good job
what a shift that's i don't know my
wife's like man you're in good mood this
morning and i think it's simply because
i didn't wake up going get off you loser
i woke up and thinking i'm gonna go get
some good stuff done today just that
tiny little shift so i'm gonna start
talking to myself more positive and
i can't man and so here's the other
honest truth the number of people who've
reached out to me on the internets and
have commented on like hey you're really
helpful and we like your show
but you gotta lay off yourself you're
always telling how dumb and idiotic you
are
i'm kidding kind of not so thank you all
for caring about me too like james does
one person who's never mentioned one
thing about it and that's kelly
kelly's just pretty much
self-focused just caring about kelly
caring about kelly
[Laughter]
hey now that we've handled your
self-talk we need to talk about how you
talk about kelly
no absolutely not that's first let's go
down that road that's for hr to discuss
we don't need to do that publicly
but i will
we'll talk about this email i got from
stephanie here's what stephanie writes
deloney been listening to you for a long
time
moved out and left my husband on january
1st 2022.
we have two boys age three and eight we
trade them every monday needless to say
it's a huge adjustment for them and for
you
two weeks ago when i got them i decided
to start giving them both 30 second hugs
three times a day my oldest is very
empathetic and is seeing the counselor
to help with the transition my youngest
has very high energy and like a
three-year-old has mercurial moods oh my
gosh great use of the word mercurial
the oldest loves the hugs
he says i count too fast so he counts
for our hugs and my hugs with the
youngest after the first couple of days
they started to change they both seemed
more settled emotionally it also helps
that we that helps me become more subtle
too
after they start to get a big stress it
reminds me that i forgot a hug
when i went to my oldest after school
care yesterday it was my first day with
him again he was very frustrated about
something i walked over and gave him a
hug and he just melted
when the time was up his emotions were
more balanced and he was able to finish
what he was doing all to say thank you
something's so small i'm glad that i
took the advice you gave someone else
and incorporated into my life
if i could tell one per two if i could
tell people two things it'll change your
life one sleep and two is physical touch
if you've got little kids
make it a priority to
in concert with them don't force
yourself on them then you traumatize
them like a
crazy person but hug your kids
touch your kids on the face hold their
hands touch kids
all right let's go to zach in
huntsville texas north of where i grew
up what's up zach
uh not much hauling freight
hauling freight that's what i'm talking
about way to go zach hey
while you're at it fix the supply chain
dude what are you doing
uh i'm
i'm just hauling stuff i just hold
whatever they tell me right now i'm
hauling a little lumber i see you i see
you passing the book hey i'm grateful
for the call brother what's up how can i
help
alrighty so uh
my father passed away back in september
and i'm sorry what from what man i'm
sorry
um
i'm not exactly sure there was a couple
of diagnoses i think it boiled down to
mainly some type of blood infection
he fought it for well over a year and a
half and
around september he finally just said
i'm sorry i can't like he even asked the
pastor if it was like against uh
against his face to like just admit he
doesn't have to fight anymore and he uh
passed away
so i'm sorry man how old are you
uh i'm 28. dang man i'm sorry brother
that's hard man
i appreciate it um
the main reason for the call though is
i'm the oldest of four i'm the oldest of
four boys i got three younger siblings
okay
my youngest brother is 15
and he seemed to be having the toughest
time with it
i don't remember i cannot really
remember how he phrased it but he was
helping with taking care of my dad when
he was having
like when some of this was going on
like he said something that hinted to
the idea that he thinks he's the reason
dad didn't get better that's exactly
right
yep and
um
i'm trying to navigate how me and my
brothers can help him out okay
and also how i can
how i can talk to my mom about certain
things that happen because
there's a couple issues number one she
gets defensive if i
ask if we can send him to counseling and
she has also
she also gets defensive if i ask for
like help with what do you want me to do
when he's having because like one of the
reasons that prompted the call is he's
having major attitude outbursts and i
don't know how to handle it my mom gets
me anytime i
try to do something about it and i
cannot i've asked her every which way
and i cannot get her to like talk to me
it's like what boundaries do you want me
to sit to get him to not have attitudes
with me and how to help him i'm not
trying to be a jerk or anything i'm
trying to be his brother i love him but
right i can't handle it if you're going
to yell at me for everything i do and i
you got to give me something yeah
yeah absolutely man well again i'm so
sorry for the loss of your dad that's
hard man whether you're 28 58 68 or 15
it's brutal all right
um
so i'll i'll walk you through a few
things here and i just want to start by
saying your brother's lucky to have you
in his life
um we're gonna i want you to
listen carefully we're gonna reorient a
few things and um
hopefully i can provide some wisdom for
you okay
the first thing is i want you to keep
this in your head this line
our childhood
biography becomes our adult biology
our childhood biography becomes our
adult biology
so
right when you said my brother was
helpful help helping take care of my dad
i wrote down the words if he had only
dot dot dot
and you you immediately followed that up
with right what i wrote down with now
he's starting to blame himself which is
exactly what happens
when kids are
brought in and let's i don't want to i
know your kid's brother's 15 he's
probably a big guy whatever he's a kid
he's a child okay
and when kids are given the
responsibility of making sure their
parents are okay physically emotionally
psychologically spiritually whatever
kids aren't strong enough to carry that
and when it inevitably goes sideways
which it always does anytime a kid is
having to prop up a parent then the kid
immediately goes what did i do or i
should have done this thing if i had
only done this thing then this would
have happened this would have been okay
and if we don't get on that right now he
will try to solve for that failure that
perceived failure that's not even real
for the rest of his life and his body
will pay the toll his relationships will
pay the toll and though these outbursts
is his body trying to work that out
right now while we're in it he's in the
middle of hard grief and it doesn't
sound like he's getting a good picture
of what grieving should look like from
your mom is that fair
yeah yeah that's very fair i
i don't know exactly what caused this my
mom's the person she don't really
like she cried at the funeral and my
brothers took a turn giving her a hug
and stuff like that but 90 percent of
her grieving has been done alone in her
room that's right so
there's a bit of an issue for this that
i think might help her if he got any
advice on this is how to approach her
about it but my aunt wendy passed away
five years ago i want to say and she was
the closest person to my mother she was
the only person aside from my dad that
she would ever break down emotionally in
front of and she's not found another
best friend since then
okay and and even then she was a family
member not a best friend right
uh technically look
we call her aunt wendy because she's
been in our life for 10 years our next
door neighbors we were very close to
them
not related but you know what i mean
actually yeah i've got several folks who
call me uncle john and same thing and
they're not i'm not related to them but
just been there in their lives to their
kids so yeah i totally get that
um oh crap i actually just forgot about
this um
maya wendy's husband
randy uh
adopted uncle
uh okay probably the most positive male
influence in all of my brother's lives i
forgot to mention this he passed away a
month before my dad died oh geez okay
yeah that's big too so it's just a lot
of trauma a lot of loss
all right so
man
couple things here one there's you and i
could probably talk for a few hours
about mom
and
there's not a lot you can do about mom
you just can't
um and i would also
i'd cut her as much grace and slack as
you possibly can
she also has that same if i had only
been able to going through her body and
head too
if i just cared this way or if or maybe
she's pissed off that he quote-unquote
quit on her
right he quit fighting for me right
and grief makes us do really gnarly
things like make the whole situation
about ourselves because we're scared
we're alone suddenly we're exposed
so when it gets to your brother
understand that your brother is taking
his cues on what should come next how he
should feel what's okay what's not okay
from the grown-ups in his life
and he's not getting a good one from his
mom right now
and what he really really needs from his
big brother is not another father
he needs a brother
okay
and it's tempting for you to come in and
be the i'm the man of the house now and
you don't talk like that that kind of
dad stuff
brothers do things a little bit
differently right and brothers can say
things a little bit differently that
dads can't say brothers are
able to bypass things the dads you know
dad's got to keep some decorum and
nonsense like that which is just part of
being a dad i got it too but brothers
can come around some of that so i want
you to keep in your mind i'm going to be
his brother not his dad okay and that's
going to be different lectures that's
going to be different the way just it's
just a posture and you've probably felt
like his dad for a long time because the
aid you have such a big age gap right
to an extent yeah like i've never like
took i never
like
thought of it as like dad but
like
i messaged my brothers to let them know
i was calling to see if they had any
questions one of the things my brother
mentioned he's like he thinks i still
view his as a child and jokingly he's
not totally wrong but even still
jokingly i was like well of course i do
he's my baby brother i'm 12 years older
than him
so i want you to elevate him because he
grew up real fast
okay he's a child
who's had adult experiences now
and his body's going to rattle for a
while trying to
toggle back and forth between that okay
so here's what he needs
like
asap are you all in the same community
in the same neighborhood
no i live in texas they live in colorado
okay
he needs somebody
does he have any any brothers and
sisters around him in colorado
um
the brother under me lives about three
hours away in denver and he regularly
communicates and tries to help out with
some of these things and then my brother
his wife and his children live with my
mom like they're kind of like sharing a
house are they stable
yeah they're stable so he needs a
brother who can take him out once a week
just them too
and he needs adults in his life talking
to him about how much they're hurting
and this sounds counter-intuitive and
backwards like we need to go to the back
room and hide our grief we cry when no
one's watching
because that's we don't want to hurt
little brother and you're stealing from
little brother you're making little
brother feel crazy
so he needs to know that you're weeping
that you're devastated that you're
heartbroken
that you you think in your head i should
have done more even though that's that's
nuts
he's desperate for that from y'all all
of y'all but he needs somebody to take
him out every week and just be a human
with him
and what you can do from from nine hours
away like you or ten hours away like you
are is you can
this is gonna sound so lame dude i'm
just telling you you can become pen pals
with him y'all can you can write him a
letter once a week and you just commit
to doing this which by the way you're
hurting too
you've gone into fix-it mode which is
what 30-year-old guys do but you're
hurting too
and
whether it's on email whether it's i'd
prefer it to be handwritten but email
will do in a pinch
a weekly phone call with him just to say
hey i'm this week
sucks how are you
and he needs to know oh my gosh my big
brother is is struggling
and
it i'm not crazy
you hear what i'm saying
his body has had two important male role
models just pulled right out from under
him and now he's gonna fill the gap with
outburst and chaos and whatever is gonna
make this pain stop hurting
and like i said he's gonna be on a
sideways track if somebody doesn't step
in there real quick
um
if the adults in his life aren't buying
this are grieving badly this ends not
well for him that's what i'll tell you
so when it comes to you you need to have
a hard conversation with your brother
that lives there with your sister-in-law
that lives there
and cut mom some slack
i would tell you at the end of the day
if he starts showing signs of he's
getting into drugs he's disappearing
he's staying alone all the time
then i would reach out and call a school
counselor i'd go around mom
and say i'm worried about my brother my
mom's dealing with her own grief in a
heavy heavy way in fact you know what
i'm gonna alter it i just said i think
y'all should call him call the school
counselor anyway
and let them know this has happened
and my mom's struggling with grief we
just want to let you know there's no
abuse or anything nobody's getting hurt
but i wanted this on y'all's radar he
needs some extra attention and some
extra care right now he needs some extra
adults in his life telling him he loves
them and i'm all the way here in texas i
just wanted to reach out with all the
resources we got
i would do that today probably make that
phone call today
um
and the counselor will reach out and
he'll probably be like no i'm cool man
i'm fun i'm cool
and i want you to let the counselor know
he's not he's not okay and he's holding
a lot of this in on himself and if
you'll check on him that'd be great and
the counselor will know in short order
if
he needs to be referred to psychological
services and things like that
but i think that'd be a gift but man if
your brother who's living with him right
now could just say hey once a week we're
going to get something to eat just the
two of us i'm checking in with you
if your brother who lives with him would
or your sister-in-law with him
would get one of those you've heard me
talk about this on the show would get a
journal that just sits on his bed that
he will write in every day and then drop
it back off on their bed and they can
just have some sort of dialogue even if
it just says the entry for february you
know 29th today sucked that's it
that's it
or
not doing okay today was okay
miss dad
those little bitty things it's a it's a
it's a it's oxygen it's just a little
breath of air little breath air a little
breath of air and
my big concern moving forward is mom is
gonna start to vampire everybody
and that she's gonna need people to take
care of her and he's gonna end up in
that role too
is that am i on to that or no
um
that's the tough that's a tough one to
figure out because my mom like despite
the fact that she's kind of hiding most
of her grief she's still a really strong
woman she's put up with a lot throughout
the years and she does her best to
take care of the family he needs to hear
that he's the mercy i give her is i know
that when she gets mad at me for
questioning like how do i deal with it
when he's doing this and stuff like that
she's trying to love him she's good well
but when you ask her that question
you're you're it's an indictment on her
parenting
and yeah she doesn't think that
if she's carrying around that somehow i
failed my husband and that's why he's
dead which is irrational but that
happens a lot
that's
we just naturally go into what could i
have done
and then her oldest son calls and he's
like yeah and what about this 15 year
old too i mean then you see what i'm
saying like that that ends up being a
heavy
load i'd rather you call him
and say not hey you need to shut your
mouth not that that's dad
hey man i heard you're really struggling
brother how's it going and if he's like
i'm not struggling be like dude i hear
how you're talking you're not doing okay
right so we're going at it like a
brother we're going at it with hey man
i'm this hurts
and you as big brother need to go first
and let him know i'm not okay you need
to go first and let him know hey by the
way your job is to love you as much as
you love dad right now
you need to turn the screens off get out
in nature make sure you're moving around
make sure you're going to lunches and
breakfasts and things like that
you need to make sure you're writing
this stuff down mail it to me i'll mail
you it back what i'm writing back to you
he needs to have some permission
to begin to take care of him taking care
of himself in the way that he's been
taking care of his dad for so long and
again all that permission has to be said
explicitly
by an adult that he cares about and who
loves him and that he knows loves him
and that's you
so know him hawing it has to be
hey your job is not to take care of mom
that's not your job
she's an adult your job is to love and
take care of you
i'm gonna send you a letter every single
week your job is to write me back
older brother who lives with him you
have to come eat with me that's just two
brother rules it's just the rule it's
gonna make it happen and on and on and
on
he's so blessed to have you in his life
but hear me say
you all got to get on him now and he
doesn't need a bunch of answers he needs
a bunch of connection
not a lot of answers a lot a lot of
connection
we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert and a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200.
trust me that's triple eight loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumer access dot org
equal housing lender 1749 mallory lane
suite 100 brentwood tennessee 37027
programs are for select loan types only
and are not available in all states or
locations
we
are
back grace in seattle washington i was
just in seattle this weekend what's up
grace oh hi john how are you doing good
i tell you what
i
seattle is one of the most beautiful
places i've ever we flew in last weekend
it is stunning how beautiful it is wow
yeah it's beautiful here so what's up
how can i help
um so first off i'm gonna say i have a
cold my voice is gonna be a little
funny
that's awesome cool
um but my question was i was wondering
if you had
any resources or tips on how to navigate
my relationship with my sister um she
has autism okay i was also wondering if
she'd help me process my childhood
growing up with her
that's a lot
um yeah so tell me about your sister
um
able to talk
yeah she's very mobile she's able to
talk she
graduated high school just a few years
later than she would normally
graduate but she's very smart
but she still has a lot of like
emotional issues i guess sure
yeah and so what was it like growing up
um
when we were little kids it was really
good because we were very close we
shared a room
but then as i got into like middle
school and high school
it was kind of hard because i felt like
i had to include her in everything i did
um
just just she did like extra
support yep
so yeah
so what what what what's happened
recently for that made you want to call
um well about five months ago i got
married
and
i have trouble feeling guilty like that
i'm not spending as much time with her
and also that it's kind of hard on my
mom to take care of her
um
are you feeling guilty are you feeling
grief
and here's the difference
guilt is this
is a violation of your personal
value system
um i did something that's against the
way i think it should have been done
or i cheated and i don't believe in
cheating i
hit somebody and i am a pacifist right
that's guilt
grief is the gap between what we wanted
or we hoped for we thought would happen
and what actually happened
and often folks who
love someone with special needs
who then transition to
basically like you're starting your own
life and your life has been on pause for
the last however many years because
whether you were told explicitly or you
felt it you've been living somebody
else's life
and yeah or you've been living two lives
at the same time or a life and a half or
whatever and now you're starting your
own and there's this grief this i can't
believe i missed my whole childhood
and not married i can't believe that
like there's nobody like no one's gonna
be able to take care of does that make
sense so is it guilt or is it grief
um and there's definitely some grief
there okay
um so sometimes i i agree that like
i don't know it sounds bad but like i
didn't have a normal childhood so yeah
so let me free you of that
they can be both and
you can
have
really uh
you can be grateful for having been able
to serve your sibling with special needs
and serve your parents in a really
challenging situation growing up
and you can weep bitterly for having not
had a childhood
both of those are okay
and in fact you have to do both and or
one of the other ones will set your body
off
okay
you'll have trauma issues on either side
of that deal you have to own what
happened
and own the fact that
kids around you just got to like their
big concern was you know what tick-tock
dance did they know and what pair of
jeans they were going to wear and you
were busy
dealing with somebody with some very
very unique needs right
and you're allowed to grieve that and
say that sucks and i wish it hadn't been
that way and boo hoo and
i love my sister i love her to death the
both of those are okay
okay okay and there's an entire industry
designed to make you feel multiple
industries to make you feel bad about
either way you think
of those on those issues right and it's
both and
um
so
what do boundaries look like moving
forward for you
i was actually going to ask you the best
way to set
because
boundaries
yeah that's hard
well i mean do you all live in the same
neighborhood
yeah we actually live in a renovated uh
trailer right now on my parents property
so that's been
a little tricky yeah i bet so um what's
your what's your
who are you married to
um
who am i what do you mean like tell me
about the person you married
okay so we met at um a discipleship
school actually about three years ago
okay um
and he's really great he um
he's like good at taking out my sister
and i together like he doesn't
he includes certain things um so have
you sat down with him and to discuss
what boundaries moving forward is going
to look like do you have a plan to get
out of the trailer and to get your own
place and to build your own life
um kind of right now it's
very at the beginning stages we're
saving up to hopefully move out um so
we're not
in the same area as my parents like
yeah
and when you say your mom can't take
care of your sister what does that mean
well she can take care of her but it's
just really hard um my parents marriage
it's like they're still married but
they're not
they're kind of like roommates so
it's been hard on her because she
doesn't get a lot of support
so grace what i'll tell you is
going to be hard to hear
okay okay
those
your mom's marriage
your mom's parenting your mom's this is
hard and i'm balancing things
those are her challenges to solve not
yours yeah and the more you carry your
mom's challenges of her marriage of her
parenting of her whatever
into your new marriage you're coming
you're bringing excess weight into that
thing that your new marriage cannot
carry you'll crash you'll crash the
whole thing
so kind of like i told you earlier it
can be both hand
you can really be sad for your mom
and that's her challenge to solve not
yours
think of it like uh you've heard me talk
about bricks in your backpack have you
ever heard me talk about that
yeah i have okay so imagine you're
holding a brick
that you're you're talking to your mom
and she's telling you about her marriage
and about this and oh my gosh i can't
believe it
and she just handed you that brick you
can hold it and you can look at it
that's what love is i'm gonna hold it
with you i'm gonna hold it for you for a
minute
and then i'm gonna hand it back to you
because i can't carry this
and sometimes for me handing it back
when i'm doing something hard is i'm
writing stuff down sometimes handing it
back there's all different ways to set
those down but
i'm not gonna carry that because i can't
do anything about it other than drown
myself trying to trying to save you
can't do anything about it okay so
repeat after me i can't fix my mom's
marriage
i can't fix my mom's marriage
and starting today
say it
i'm starting today i'm gonna stop trying
i'm going to stop trying
i can love my sister say it
i can love my sister
but i'm not her mom
but i'm not her mom there you go
so here's what i want you to do i want
you and your husband to go out
i don't want you all to dream real big
not in a cheesy way nothing like
but in a
in three years what would our life look
like
and then this is gonna be hard i want
y'all to reverse engineer that
what do we have to start doing today
this week this weekend next week next
month
so that this happens
and this dream may have a dollar amount
attached to it
this dream may have we're gonna have our
own place this dream may be we're gonna
move to texas i don't i don't really
know what it's gonna be
but we're gonna reverse engineer it and
when it comes to your sister
it's gonna be some reverse engineering
that will look like hey mom we're gonna
have we're gonna work really hard to
save up this much money which means i
gotta start working three jobs over the
next 12 to 18 months
so i'm not gonna be able to come pick up
sis
i'm just not gonna i'm not gonna have
the bandwidth to do it and so i'm
letting you know ahead of time i used to
i usually do these things
great hey sister we are going to come up
with an every two
every two weeks
you and i are going to go out together
it's going to be our thing
but we're doing is we're gently setting
up boundaries so that your sister can
have a day to prep plan
you can have a day to plan but you also
have 13 days off in between to have to
live your life because you've never had
to live your life right
yeah
and that's both a blessing and a curse
it's a blessing because you've been able
to pour into somebody else for so long
but i don't know that you know how
right so you're gonna have to practice
how to have your own life you're gonna
find yourself bored to death when you
get bored you're going to either do
you're going to pick up your phone and
start scrolling or you're going to try
to reinsert yourself back into mom's
drama
yeah
you got to find new am i am i right
yeah so you got to find new coping
mechanisms you have to find new things
to get involved with and my hope is
those are going to be
taking care of you taking care of this
knucklehead new husband of yours taking
care of your new baby marriage right
um whatever that's going to look like
working towards those things that you
guys decided you all wanted to to work
towards
and
expect some pushback expect to feel
guilty expect lots of grief
what do i do when i uh feel guilty and
grief like how do i handle it write it
down
write it down okay
i would have a guilty and grief journal
that's just yours and the magic of grief
is you have to have a witness you've got
to have somebody that you're talking to
so if that means you've got to find a
counselor you'll build that into your
budget then do that now
i would recommend
since you don't have a good picture of
what a healthy marriage looks like
you're kind of making this up as you go
and your parents didn't become roommates
overnight
it happened over time yeah they probably
were in love when they got together
that's my guess maybe not but that's my
guess
and
so roommate-ness
it's not really a diagnostic i should
make that up though roommateness happens
to the best of us it's happened to me it
happens to everybody and you've got to
intentionally lean out of it
or lean way way into it
i would love to see you and your husband
go to counseling now why y'all are
healthy and why things are y'all are
young and while your marriage is new
and you all begin practicing language
that's going to be boundary language
love language desire language you're
going to learn some skills right now
that will pay off 20 30 40 years from
now
okay
and here's the word i want you to keep
in your head keep this in your head keep
this in your head practice
practice practice practice you're going
to practice boundaries you're going to
practice telling your sister not today
you're going to practice not getting
involved there's going to be times you
call your mom just out of habit and be
like
hey how's dad and then you're going to
go nope nope no no i'm stopping i'm
stopping i'm stopping i don't want to
know that's your husband
you're right you're practicing this
you're going to start to pick up your
cell phone when you're bored
no put it down put it down you're going
to practice it right
and then you're going to think what's
one thing i could do to love my husband
right this second we're gonna do that
i'm gonna lean that way right so we're
gonna practice practice everything
moving forward is practicing
and like everyone in practice who wants
to get good at something you get a coach
i was with a professional coach this
morning you're going to find a coach
that's going to help you and that's
going to be your marriage counselor or
some pastor that you trust that's not a
goofball
making stuff up or whoever right so
man your sister's lucky to have you
lucky two have had you and you're not
going anywhere for a while your
husband's lucky to have you let's start
changing the family tree today we'll be
right back
do you want a better life a better
marriage better mental and physical
health the single most important action
you can take to improve your mental and
physical health to change your entire
life
is to get enough deep restorative
quality sleep i know this from research
and as a guy who has struggled with
sleep for my entire life and for me good
sleep starts with a world-class mattress
it's why my family sleeps on dream cloud
mattress dream cloud is advanced
technology and you can buy in the store
or you can do it like i did and have it
shipped directly to your house
dreamcloud is running their biggest
offer ever exclusively for dr john
doloni's show listeners 399 bucks and
accessories plus an additional 250
discount that's a total of 649
in accessories and savings pillows
mattress protectors luxury sheets all of
it it's time to stop sleeping on your
old college mattress or the old
hand-me-down from grandma and start
changing your life visit
dreamcloudsleep.com or dreamcloud sleep
and enter promo code deloney and get
your new mattress today
all right let's take one more let's go
back to washington to spokane and talk
to my new best friend mary what's up
mary
oh
oh oh one of those
yeah
and donna
i don't even know
hey i don't even know what's going on
but i'm so grateful that you called
what's up
so
[Applause]
thank you
it's great to talk to you
um it's better to talk to you
i've been
together with my current
well only spouse for the past nine years
we've been married for
eight
and
um
eight of those years there's
been abuse going on
um gosh what kind of abuse
all of them okay
and
uh we have two kids
and things really
um
really got bad a few years ago
when um
when
our daughter went through a challenging
time and she needed weekly counseling
that i took her to and it was just
it was hard on everybody but i was
trying to get her healthy
so
drinking started
happening more frequently
with you or
your husband
with him
um
and
i've been with the same personal
counselor
this entire time
our kids have the same counselor
and so they know all of it
some reporting has happened
are kids safe
yes
are they watching things are they seeing
things happen to their mother they
shouldn't be seeing
yeah okay
um
the physical stuff has not happened
since
about seven months ago six months ago
when he
um
last did it but
was never you know on the brink of
death or anything
but he just got arrested
he did get arrested
yeah okay goodbye
he got arrested he was charged
and there was no contact order in place
and then he got another charge
and now he's on probation okay
but for some circumstances um
he's now
he's
i'm sorry this is hard no of course it's
hard take your time
um i've been making plans for quite a
while
to leave him but i haven't really found
the strength to do so because my parents
had
the world's nastiest with a capital n
divorce
and
it was
terrible and i don't really remember
much
from my childhood
because of my own
assault that was happening at that time
but as i'm kind of peeling back those
layers more memories are coming back and
i can't i just i don't really remember
them married
um but what i do remember the most is
how alone i felt when my parents did
separate
and um
although i've i've made the steps i've
never really made that big leap to
finally been be done and move forward
with my two kids
our two kids
but i did have a conversation with him
early last week
and i told him i was done and
in the first time
for the first time in the last
eight years
he wasn't defensive um or
denying um
that anything has happened
but i don't trust that this
is gonna last because
he usually does um
he's usually good for a week
maybe
mary mom you know
so i guess i'm just really trying to
figure out um
because a lot of words were thrown
around last week that have kind of
thrown me off which is
i i'm the one wrecking the family and
it's marriage
mary
yeah
you know
yeah
you know
you're worth more than all of this
and there's a moment now
where you get to for the first time in a
decade
finally love yourself enough
to scratch and claw yourself back to two
feet
and say i'm worth more than this
and especially these two little babies
are worth more than this
there's no words
there's no i promise you
there's no you have a baby this time
it's
10 years
10 years
your parents divorce is not your
separation
your body remembers that trauma my guess
is
a lot of your childhood trauma got
pinned on that divorce
what do i mean by that
my guess is
my guess is it probably is not as bad as
you remember it the actual divorce
my guess is it got wound up in a whole
bunch of other stuff i may be way wrong
on that
but my guess is there was a lot of abuse
going on a lot of trauma going along a
lot of screaming and yelling and stuff
that terrified a child
that got pinned on
and i say pinned on our bodies just do
this man um in trauma trauma screws up
our memories big time
they got pinned on the divorce process
oh
and my guess is it wasn't that
and
hear me real clear when i say i'm about
to say okay
you can do the right thing
and it still hurts like hell
leaving
leaving an abuser
someone who i mean just listening to
your language he hasn't done it in six
months
and he's out of jail now and he's saying
and i was never really close to death
all of those things are ways we just try
to make
what we have happened to us okay so that
we can just keep stumbling forward
and you deserve more than a stumble
forward life
and so this is the end of an era end of
a decade this is end of a fantasy you've
had this end of a picture this is not
what you signed up for and it slowly
became what you're the hell on earth
that you were living
all of that's gonna hurt
when you finally say no more i'm worth
more than this
it's gonna hurt bad and that doesn't
mean it's the wrong thing
if you have a heart blockage they have
to break your ribs and open your chest
up to fix your heart it hurts and it's
right just like this
okay i think i'm doing it more so that
the kids could see that i know i know
but you because and if you have to do it
for the kids fine
but i'm telling you
you're worth doing it for you
nobody deserves to live in the horror
in the fear and i can't sleep and my
body's not my own body
yeah
nobody has to should live like that
careful
nobody
but i also know after a decade of living
like that it's hard for to even look in
the mirror and say believe that
your body feels it right now as i'm
saying it i know it does but
it's hard to even believe it cognitively
so fine do it for your kids
but you and me my friend mary
do this for you
because you're worth this
and when i say you're worthless here's
what you're worth
can you imagine just falling asleep at
night and sleeping all night
you imagine getting just to decide if
you're gonna have sex or not
can you imagine not getting hit over
something stupid like you bought the
wrong beer or whatever
or you forgot to pay a bill
what i mean when you're worth it you're
worth going to sleep you're worth
laughing
you're worth wrestling around with your
kids and not having to worry the house
out of place or whatever's going on in
your home for the last eight years
so hear me say this
there is no more conversations
conversations have been had
and you know as well as i do
the
my guess is he is a master at lobbing
emotional and verbal grenades at you
that will cut to your core and will cut
back to that little girl who's still
trying to fix her parents marriage from
way back in the day still wondering what
she did to deserve the abuse that she
that you endured as a child am i right
yeah yeah that crap wasn't your fault
you're you're a baby girl man
should not have happened
your body's trying to solve it now and
this is how these things happen
generationally is some guy finds
somebody who's still trying to solve it
and he tries to be that solution it
makes you crazy
okay
okay
here's what i want you to do today i
want you to write that little girl a
letter
i want you to write you when you were
nine a letter
will you do that
yeah
and i want you to let her know that
she's a sweet little girl and it's time
for her to go play
because the adults in her life suck
and they've hurt her for too long and no
more
now grown-up mary's back
and we're gonna start turning stuff
around
and now little girl mary can go play
okay we do that
yeah do you have somebody to walk
alongside you during this it's gonna be
hard this guy sucks
maybe yeah
so hear me say you can't do this by
yourself okay mary you gotta have
somebody to walk with you
okay
all right
have you called a lawyer already
yeah okay hey i've had one retained
make sure you go to the next appointment
you promise me you won't skip the next
appointment
promise
like i don't have one scheduled so i
feel like that's a little bit
one will come up one will come up and
then you're going to be talked out of
going
or you're going to talk yourself out of
going
and that's where having somebody with
you that's going to be your
accountability partner that's going to
go with you it's going to show up with
you it's going to call you and be like
nope because everything in your body's
gonna want to skip this part
yeah
and you gotta go
you just told me and all 11 of our
listeners
actually we've got millions you just
told millions of people
that you're in
and we're walking alongside you and
we're walking with you
i'll say it one more time you my friend
mary are worth being loved
you're worth going to sleep
you're worth laughter you're worth joy
you're worth people being patient with
you you're worth screwing stuff up
figuring out and having somebody laugh
with you and walk alongside you
your kids are worth all that too
we'll be right back
[Music]
for the past two decades i've worked
with students parents those on the
margins and those who seem to have
everything i've met with law enforcement
military folks struggling single moms
company presidents and everybody in
between and there is one thread that
weaves through all of these different
people that you
me we
are so
lonely we don't have real in-depth safe
relationships and hear me say this you
cannot be well alone
you can't do life by yourself you got to
get connected to real life people and
have deep relationships i'm talking
relationships where you can be yourself
share hard things and know you'll show
up for one another in my new book own
your past change your future we'll walk
through a not so complicated approach to
relationships mental health and wellness
and getting connected because it's a key
part of living a good life you'll learn
why shallowness and loneliness are so
dangerous you'll even learn how to start
making real friends so go to
johndaloney.com to take the next step
towards wellness that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right as we wrap up today's show i'm
gonna end it with uh
two things one
some positivity good job james benjamin
kelly
just kidding you did great kelly you did
great you did great
song of the day is from my favorite band
the avett brothers
off the magpie and the dandelion record
2013 it came out and the song is another
is waiting and it goes like this it's a
fake it's a hoax it's a nowhere road
where no one goes anywhere anyhow
well you're following your heart rate
down she's a rose she's a queen but
she's staring at a magazine in the dark
on the path where they doctor every
photograph another is waiting she isn't
saying anything but if you care if you
like well i'm standing in the lantern
light with our weapons and our love and
i use them both to cover up
come on guys these guys are so good
we'll see you soon